cuando era niño me interesaban los
deportes me gustaba jugar afuera pero a
nivel académico me encantaban las mates
y la ciencia en una ocasión por navidad
mis papás me dieron un juego de química
y me volví loco con él casi incendió la
casa
mi primera película en pixar fue
parcialmente nublado un cortometraje
dirigido por [ __ ] son los personajes de
las nubes originalmente tenían una
superficie dura pero usamos las
partículas para moverlos en nubes
esponjosas lo que más me gusta de ser un
artista de efectos especiales es la
variedad me toca ser agua fuego fuegos
artificiales humo polvo un poco de todo
en efectos especiales siempre trabajamos
en equipos dividimos el trabajo en
varias tomas pero siempre examinamos el
trabajo de los demás y comparamos
nuestras técnicas nuestras soluciones a
los problemas es un gran esfuerzo de
colaboración intercambiamos ideas unos
con otros e intentamos hacer coincidir
el aspecto visual entre todo el equipo
en los efectos especiales normalmente
nos enfrentamos con problemas grandes y
difíciles y casi siempre nos equivocamos
la primera vez y la segunda y también la
tercera porque hacemos las cosas
una y otra y otra vez hasta que nos
quedan bien
debo de haber hecho algunas de las tomas
más difíciles al menos 15 o 20 veces
antes de que quedaran bien e incluso
entonces puede ser necesario repetirlas
unas cuantas veces más para obtener la
precisión adecuada